es sei für außenstehende sicher
befremdlich sagt wolfgang barth aber man
müsste das sehen wenn man die
frankfurter drogenpolitik verstehen
wolle in den konsum räumen des zentrums
dürfen abhängige sich unter aufsicht
heroin spritzen das sie mitgebracht
haben
die utensilien bekommen sie gestellt
sie alle sind schwer drogenabhängig
schnell wird klar hier geht es nicht in
erster stelle darum diese menschen von
den drogen weg zu bekommen
warum es findet kein konsum mehr auf der
straße statt es findet ihr unter
hygienischen bedingungen das was das
stichwort tarmed aktien das heißt
reduzierung der gefahren die mit dieser
aufwendigen ungefährlichen
applikationsform verbunden sind und
ordnung gewährleistet ist dass im falle
einer überdosierung eines tropen
notfalls so folgt geschultes personal
hinter denen
wolfgang barth arbeitet seit 33 jahren
in der drogentherapie er weiß wie
wichtig es ist dass die abhängigen hier
einen geschützten ort haben
vor der tür sieht die welt ganz anders
aus hier im bahnhofsviertel zu drehen
ist nur mit versteckter kamera möglich
das misstrauen bei den drogenabhängigen
ist groß
[Musik]
es gibt aber auch einige die in ihrem
rausch nichts mitbekommen
viele sagen dass sich die lage nach zwei
jahren coroner lockdown deutlich
verschärft hat
[Musik]
philipp lahm ist manager eine
apartmentanlage im bahnhofsviertel und
regt sich nicht nur über den vielen müll
auf den er jeden tag selbst erklären
muss er habe den eindruck dass selbst
die müllabfuhr ihren dienst hier
mittlerweile quittiert haben
diesen winter ist immer schlimmer
geworden auf jeden fall also ich bin
seit fast ein bisschen mehr als einem
jahr da und gekommen ist von unserem
fenster reinigungsfirma gesagt von
stammgästen sie hat schon über einem
jahr auch hier sind unser security am
wochenende gesagt es wird immer
schlimmer als am wochenende
nachmittags zieht ihr aus teilweise wenn
wir an risen haben
fremdschämen ist es einfacher noch
schlimmer sei allerdings dass sich vor
der tür der anlage immer wieder süchtige
niederlassen um ihre drogen zu
konsumieren
[Musik]
merken sie dass schon das durchaus ja
also ich meine alle unsere gäste sagen
erst mal auf gott wo bin ich hier
eigentlich gelandet eben in größter
können wie irgendwie abfangen hat mit
freundlichkeit ein bisschen charme und
dergleichen aber halt nicht jeden gast
diese leute rauchen crack die droge ist
billig macht sofort abhängig verlangt
ständig nach nachschub
die süchtigen direkt vor seinem
restaurant das erlebt james dean hast
jeden tag für ihn ist die drogenpolitik
der stadt gescheitert der sogenannte
frankfurter weg sah vor die süchtigen
von der straße zu holen das gegenteil
aber sei der fall
es gibt immer noch die heroin
konsumierenden aber es sind
hauptsächlich die
track konsumierenden die menschen die
süchtig geben nach cracks sind crack ist
ein ist eine droge die die menschen
aggressiver macht und dadurch verändert
sich auch der flair auf der straße und
zurzeit wirkt es einfach so als wäre man
recht ratlos das explodiert also es
kommen inzwischen auch drogenkranker aus
ganz deutschland nach frankfurt weil sie
eben wissen dass sie hier alles finden
was sie brauchen hier besteht diese
infrastruktur es gibt die dealer
die auf der straße umlaufen man trifft
sich vor den fixerstuben und das nimmt
einfachen niveau an das kaum noch
auszuhalten ist
die abhängigen von der straße zu holen
das versuchen die sozialarbeiter der
organisation ost jeden tag wolfgang
barth ist auf jeder leiter was ist die
dreharbeiten mit ihnen müssen wir gleich
abbrechen
die drogenabhängigen versuchen uns
anzugreifen
warum ist es jetzt so aggressiv gewesen
also ich gehe davon aus dass die angst
haben dass die polizei etwas mitbekommt
und die sagten später verfolgt oder auch
wegen der familie dass die familie
angriffe das zu sehen
doch doch mit mit beziehungsarbeit kann
man die leute erreichen dass sich ja
nicht so dass man mit den baukran
kontakt haben und mit denen ich arbeiten
kann aber das muss erst mal so ein
gewisser grund beziehung stehen damit
die leute einen vertrauen und wissen
dass mal ein böses will die erfolgreiche
arbeit
wir können schon so einige sachen
bewegen und erreichen auch die querten
erreichen die behörden sie stellen wurde
angedockt werden können und können mit
dem eigentlich zusammenarbeiten
das zeigt auch das beispiel dieses
mannes der seinen namen nicht nennen
will er war lange heroinabhängig und es
dank der sozialarbeiter von sap auf
einem guten weg und sonst noch irgendwas
offen oder daran nichts offen hat meine
führungsaufsicht lange weg
keine offenen verfahren
meine situation gerade ist halt keine
eigene wohnung bin in der notunterkunft
und
gehalt dosen flaschen sammeln
ich brauche ab und zu mal was ja aber
nicht mehr so viel wie in meinem bein
was ist passiert da habe ich nicht eine
thrombose gehabt und habe ich
mitgekriegt
sie werden schon so unterstützt von
allen seiten
ist weg von den
rovers ja
er ist im methadonprogramm ein wichtiger
bestandteil des frankfurter drogen nur
dienstes hier bekommen die abhängen
dieses ersatzmittel dass sie weg bringen
soll vom gefährlichen heroin
man könne nicht erwarten dass sie alle
abstinent werden sagt michael schmidt
der arzt hier
das für eine völlig unrealistische
sylvie versuchen wie zu stabilisieren
körperlich und vor allem sozial dass
auch die sozialarbeit die zimmer neben
dran ist also eine ganz wichtige hilfe
wird mit adonia wirklich nur sozusagen
der türöffner ist für die ganze therapie
und wenn wir das geschafft haben die zu
stabilisieren versuchen wir die leute
weiter zu vermitteln und welche aus dem
bahnhofsviertel zu bringen und da kann
dann auch eine abstinenz erfolgen und es
erfolgt auch die humanitäre sprechstunde
die es hier gibt es besonders wichtig da
schaffen wir es leute zu erreichen die
halt ohne krankenversicherung
ausgeschlossen werden sonst für das
substitution und für mich erst noch mal
einen schlauch für die tollen
möglichkeiten finden die auch in der
entlüftungsleitung stationäre therapie
es sei in frankfurt einiges getan worden
sagen ulrich mattner und tom holz die
die drogenszene hier gut kennen
regelmäßig bieten sie dazu informations
touren an der frankfurter weg sagen sie
sei durchaus erfolgreich gewesen
doch nun stagnieren
und es müsse auf jeden fall weitergehen
das musste wohnräume für die leute geben
wir mussten hier von der straße weg
geholt werden es gibt dieses haus in
fast konzept das wäre schon mal an der
basis eine durchgehende medizinischer
versorgung viele der menschen hier so
eines krankenversichert aus welchen
gründen auch immer ganz unterschiedlich
sie sind mit ihren medizinischen
natürlich völlig unterversorgt ja wir
hatten jetzt 2020 jeder 40 drogentote
das ist das zweithöchste in 25 jahren
und das zeigt für mich da ist keine kein
abwärts drin wenn du die stadt fragt der
was was habt ihr in fünf jahres plan wo
soll die zahl der drogentoten liegen wo
die zahl der der konsum vorgänge in den
konnten den druck von soll das weiter
runtergehen nein die haben keinen plan
da ist nichts
stephan mayer der gesundheitsdezernent
weist solche vorwürfe zurück das geld
für die drogenhilfe sei von sechs auf
elf millionen euro erhöht worden er
glaubt aber dass die polizei mehr machen
müsse wir haben eine hilfseinrichtung
die hat eine offene tür wir haben
übernachtungsangebote die in anspruch
genommen werden kann aber auf der
anderen seite muss stehen dass auch die
ordnungsbehörden sagen und hier ist
schluss und es gibt nicht nur das recht
eines drogenabhängigen sondern es gibt
auch das recht der anderen
die polizei frankfurt ist zu keinem
interview bereit teilt uns aber
schriftlich mit dass sie alles tue was
rechtlich möglich sein wir beobachten
sie mehrfach im bahnhofsviertel dazu
sagt uns die polizei dass es hier vor
allem darum gehe den illegalen handel
mit drogen zu unterbinden und
begleiterscheinungen wie belästigungen
oder vermüllung zu minimieren
das gelingt offensichtlich nicht gut die
bewohner des bahnhofsviertels jedenfalls
finden es werde viel zu wenig getan
auch philipp flath ist der meinung
wir sehen hier ja wochen monate
teilweise keine polizei hierdurch auch
keine polizist oder so was also da ist
parken frei
und natürlich auch die straßenreinigung
wo wir denken hier ist wochenlang
teilweise gar keiner sie müsste
eigentlich jeden tag durch
der fotograf ulrich mattner hat konkrete
vorschläge für die stadt
frankfurt der weg müsse jetzt sagen okay
wir haben jetzt das heim geführt wie den
konsum räume und jetzt betrachten wir
die mehr als kranke wir versuchen den
noch mehr angebote zu machen wir
versuchen vor allen dingen den wohnung
zu verschaffen was in zürich gemacht
worden ist viele sagen nicht die droge
ist das problem das leben auf der straße
macht uns kaputt ja und diese strecke
gezeugt das heroin hat hier einen
reinheitsgrad von vier bis acht prozent
der rest ist dreck konsumieren dreck in
öffentlich finanzierten räumen nicht nur
den konsum sondern auch den handel in
die drogen zentren zu verlegen um mehr
kontrolle zu bekommen das hat man in
zürich getan auch die stadt frankfurt
kann sich das vorstellen
rechtlich ist das allerdings nach dem
betäubungsmittelgesetz nicht möglich
insgesamt sei es so dass viele
drogensüchtige die hilfe gar nicht
annehmen würden
wir haben das in den vergangenen zwei
jahren gemacht dass wir hotels
angemietet haben und drogenabhängige
untergebracht haben weil wir natürlich
auch während koronalen eine besondere
herausforderung haben aber wir können
niemand dazu zwingen
jetzt tatsächlich eine solche hilfe auch
ein übernachtungs hilfe anzunehmen
gerade wegen ihrer schweren sucht sind
einige für die angebotene hilfe nicht
zugänglich
die sozialarbeiter von ossip versuchen
es dennoch jeden tag
[Musik]
auch den handel von drogen in die konsum
räume zu verlegen könnte wie in zürich
dafür sorgen dass es solche bilder nicht
mehr gibt
die sucht dieser menschen zu bekämpfen
bleibt das größte problem
[Musik]